comme chaque année le salon des arts
ménagers a choisi sa magicienne la fée
du logis 1956 dans les sous sols du
grand palais elle était 120 en
compétition pour les demi finales cent
vingt jeunes filles et jeunes femmes
venus de toutes les provinces de france
après avoir triomphé des preuves
multiples départementales et régionales
une fée du logis ne peut être bien sûr
kabyle cordon bleu pour en juger on leur
fit faire des rissoles des pommes
meringuée c'est l'union nationale des
caisses d'allocations familiales qui
organise ce grand concours
d'enseignement ménager
après la cuisine le raccommodage c'est
difficile la pose d'une pièce ronde
l'aspirante fait est interrogé par une
technicienne des sciences ménagères
mademoiselle morin l'une des
organisatrices du concours
il fallut encore taillé recoudre la
barboteuse deux bébés dans un tissu rayé
et le raccord des rayures
c'est aussi une technique délicate
[Musique]
la fée du logis sera naturellement la
plus compétente des mamans la
puériculture est à l'honneur et les
résultats fort encourageants
quand l'enseignement ménager progresse
la mortalité infantile diminue des mains
adroites des mains de fée ce n'est pas
suffisant on exige aussi de la meilleure
ménagères de france des connaissances
précises et c'est le moment que jamais d
exprimer clairement la sélection est
sévère de ses 120 concurrente des demi
finales il ne restera que 20 rescapés
pour affronter la finale
les voici cette année nos vins lauréate
avait rendez vous chez crizal ce fut un
aimable divertissement
l'irruption de la technique du 20e
siècle parmi les femmes savantes
dernière épreuve pour les championnes de
l'art ménagers convaincre philaminte et
belize des miracles de l'électricité du
gaz de la mécanique avec martine martine
la soubrette au solide bon sens c'est
plus facile à l'est conquise par la
matière peste
[Musique]
rené manger l'auteur du divertissement
philaminte abdiquent devant les pouvoirs
de la machine à laver
la fée du logis gagnera non seulement
son joli titre mais aussi des
instruments de sa puissance deux
cuisinières à gaz à l'électricité
une machine à laver une machine à coudre
et bien d'autres cadeaux le xviie siècle
souri à la technique moderne
leur approche on va connaître l'heureuse
lauréate
on apprend d'abord le nom des ses
suivants annick lottin 17 ans d'ille et
vilaine jacqueline père à 18 ans venus
de la corrèze la fée du logis
la fée du logis c'est madame paulette
lavaud 26 ans présenté par la caisse
d'allocations familiales de reims elle
est mariée elle a deux enfants crizal
gageons le envieraient son époux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la guêpe au guépard en passant par le
père sang bleu et le poney ce sont là
avec un chinchilla vivant le voici
regarder de près les bêtes que les
belles nous ont présenté au gala de la
belle et la bête le dixième une
tradition les bénéfices en aller comme
toujours à une oeuvre charitable
l'oeuvre des amis de la banlieue c'est
peut-être un peu tôt à moins que ce ne
soit un vison non c'est un renard
dussart qui fascine de futures belles
celui-ci visons méchant en cage la belle
est assouplie
pour un manteau il en faudrait 80 c'est
ce que pensent les photographes
[Musique]
la dame blonde à 2 erden fauves comme il
se doit
[Musique]
mademoiselle de contades à un peu n'est
qui lui appartient et qui la suit
partout
un groupe de champions l'ouvrier à poils
longs
il y avait même une dame et sa licorne
tout au moins 20 mauvaise la firme sur
la couverture du programme tapis de
velours pour le poney
[Musique]
bras de satin pour le scarabée sacré
sacrés vivant
[Musique]
enfin charme conjugués des belles et des
bêtes pour ce 10e gala
[Musique]
dans un jardin qui ne devait durer
qu'une nuit et qui a été spécialement
créée par ce poète en paysage et roberge
au fait vous allez assister au gala
élégance et automobile
en même temps que les membres du jury en
même temps que les spectateurs
vous voyez se dérouler devant vous la
finale du rallye du coton longues fibres
regardez la bien
ce numéro 16 regardez bien toutes les
concurrentes finalistes de cannes de
paris du touquet de bordeaux de toutes
les villes l'une d'elles la gagnante
fera un merveilleux voyage et elle sera
désignée quand le jury aura fini de
délibérer
signalons la présence dans ce jury de
maïté célarié sannois de madame tous
dautrecque duc de brissac ce gala était
donné au bénéfice de l'association pour
l'aide à la transfusion sanguine
sous le patronage du comité officiel des
fêtes de paris deux en même temps cela
précède de peu le final
[Musique]
pendant que les notes du jury sont
examinés que les points sont additionnés
et que les concurrentes retiennent leur
souffle et espère nous allons nous
assister
présenté par jean de faucon à l'arrivée
des voitures de luxe européennes chaque
voiture ayant naturellement à son bord
une élégante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'arrivée des madmoizelles
madeleine le body habillée par jacques m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suivi de mademoiselle françoise hauata
organdi blanc brodé pour la robe et pour
l'ombre elle
[Musique]
mademoiselle and de panafieu habillée
par germaine le compte de dentelle
blanche est parée de turquoise
[Musique]
mademoiselle florence l'alouette
habillée par jacques aymes de satin de
coton blanc imprimé bleu longue sombre
le deal de brissac maintenant telle
constance de toulouse lautrec organdi et
guipure de coton blanc manteau bleu vif
de jean patou
[Musique]
madame berges mination manteau blanc
très sobre sur une robe en dentelle
blanche de jean patou aussi
[Musique]
la comtesse bruno doncieux de chaffardon
a choisi la robe de grand soir de jeanne
lanvin
[Musique]
m
la neige est astucieuse vous descendez
les champs elysées dans la grisaille et
vlan vous êtes en savoir claire pu les
pentes la vitesse oui mais pour faire du
ski
il faut être plus souple lui au moins il
a l'air d'un sportif d'un vrai elle elle
est comédienne pour passer en souplesse
de la scène à la piste fait de la
gymnastique
rien qu'un peu tous les jours et ce
sportif ils lui parlent un langage de
sportifs marché mais oui marché avec de
longues foulées pour la souplesse le
souffle rien n'est meilleur
il n'y a que les premiers pas qui coûte
oui ils passent par le bitume de paris
le chemin pour des sports d'hiver
réussis à la prochaine fois il faudra
mettre des souliers plan comme dirait
molière le chemin est long du projet à
la chose
les escaliers quelle aubaine si vous
habitez au 6e sans ascenseur vous
deviendrez championne mais encore
faut-il les gravir ces escaliers talons
en dehors pointe bien à plat pour les
muscles du mollet pour des jambes sans
défaillance on ne fait pas mieux à elle
se mérite les joies de la neige
la providence rend parfois la silhouette
reposant d'un vieil autobus s'asseoir et
la plateforme alors pour apprendre à
absorber les chocs
il a su la convaincre mais il a des
lettres de noblesse c'est écrit sur son
visage georges ima est professeur
d'éducation physique
il est même chargé de la préparation
physique de l'équipe de france de ski de
fond le ski ça le connaît
et le hasard fait bien les choses
[Musique]
l'ascenseur n'aurait-elle rien retenu et
les escaliers alors
[Musique]
est-ce larmes de la vengeance
enfin des chaussures de sportive
[Musique]
mais au diable la facilité le laçage des
souliers et voyons pour le ski encore un
éducatif à portée de la main enfin pas
tant que ça les jeunes ou bien raide une
épine dorsale élastique
ça vaut bien ce nouvel effort
[Musique]
et songez marguerite qu en frottant
votre parquet vous le ferez briller bien
sûr mais en même temps quelle souplesse
promise à vos articulations vous le
ramasserez tout seul votre gant et vous
en éviterez des mésaventures
[Musique]
pour l' équilibre maintenant
esquissant équilibre il vaut mieux ne
pas songer au début on n'est pas très à
son aise mais après après c'est drôle
c'est un jeu nommé bongo marc bury
cassant vous aurez bien gagner un voyage
dans la neige sans accident c'est en
courbatures les courbatures on en
reparlera demain
[Musique]
cette jeune femme a une jolie ligne elle
veut la garder d'autres femmes elles
souhaiteraient la retrouver qui bien se
pèse bien se connaît mais un maître
aussi est excellent pour contrôler
l'évolution d'une silhouette
car finalement ce qui compte ce n'est
pas tant le poids que le volume et sa
répartition
[Musique]
cette table d'exercice réalisé dans une
grande université américaine à la
demande du président fondateur d'une
méthode que l'on applique dans 78 une
beauté aux états unis et dans une
succursale parisienne permet
l'amaigrissement localiser là où il est
souhaitable elle peut à raison de deux
ou trois séances de 45 minutes par
semaine en un nombre de semaines qui
dépend de l'importance de la
transformation à accomplir diminuer
notablement le tour de taille le tour de
hanches chasser la cellulite qui
alourdit le modeler des cuisses ou des
chevilles redressé à dos qui s'attriste
redonner à une femme une silhouette
jeune et en même temps une authentique
jeunesse
[Musique]
oui
exercice passif qui n'est donc pas
fatiguant qui n'oblige pas à une tenue
spéciale et qui même ne décoiffe pas
[Musique]
l'exercice passif est contrôlée qui
allonge affine tonifie durci améliore la
circulation et qui gagnent bien sûr à
être accompagnée d'un régime riche en
protéines
c'est fini
[Musique]
leblanc 1956 et moins blanc que jamais
il devient encore plus fantaisistes
toujours plus gai il est rayé brodé
fleury imprimés comme c'est spirituel
mouchoir de couleur chaque mouchoirs
vaut 130 points le mouchoir calendrier à
choisir quand on est distraite
à moins que vous ne préfériez la bonne
humeur de cette anecdote
[Musique]
la joueuse en portera le joker est là
sentimentale la phrase qui l'a fait
rêver
[Musique]
rayon des nappes si vous êtes tenté par
la couleur pensait qu'elle devra
s'harmoniser avec les nuances de la
salle à manger
elle est verte cette nappe en coton
décorée de fougères andry mécanique 7500
francs pour six couverts cette nappe
créé mais en pure fil de lin c'est clair
des couleurs vives des fleurs des champs
[Musique]
ces broderies à jour et sont italienne
elle s'incruste dans une toile pur fils
7300 francs pour six couverts pour les
soirs de grande réception cette
somptueuse n'a blanche en toile pur fils
enrichit le jour et de broderie au point
de venise 43 mille francs pour 12
couverts d'un prix plus accessibles neuf
mille neuf cent francs pour six couverts
cette nappe ronde en toile delà d'un
bourreau soutenu en contraste broderies
blanches exécuté à la main
enfin si vous avez un intérieurs
rustiques ou tout simplement si le lâche
basse que vous plaît vous n'aurez que
l'embarras du choix
zébré de couleurs vives bordé de franges
ou relais à jour le linge basque et
d'une grande variété
[Musique]
mais l'idée nouvelle idée originale du
blanc 1956 c'est le torchon imprimés
avec ses fruits avec ses légumes avec
ses instruments de la vie ménagères de
teintes éclatantes
il est gay il est amusant il peut se
métamorphoser en un joyeux tablier le
l'âge est optimiste en 1956 il est aussi
pratique
d'après le dessin choisi il dit tout de
suite son nom avec le torchon imprimés
vous ne confondrait plus le torchon à
casserole avec les suivait il vaut 375
francs dans leur ensemble les prix du
blanc sont cette année en légère baisse
3 5% par rapport à 1955
où les créateurs de la haute coiffure
parisienne of steel l'inspiration en
contemplant les visages féminins
sûrement et le visage de nicole courcel
est un ravissant point de départ en
allant dans les expositions aux courses
à la montagne en asie au cinéma quelques
fois ainsi dans le dernier film de walt
disney que nous verrons à paris en avril
prochain
le personnage principal et davy crockett
trappeur chasseurs d'ours qui a
participé brillamment à l'indépendance
du texas et qui traverse le folklore
américain coiffé de cette toque de
fourrure qui va si bien à nipple conseil
[Musique]
topp qui attend plus un célèbre trio de
coiffure parisien qu'ils ont créé des
postiches de cheveux rappelant le bonnet
de davy crockett pour rester là blain
cheveux bruns je veux bras sur sa tête
et cheveux bruns pour imiter la fourrure
car cette dup est un cheveu
[Musique]
et en cheveux également mais en cheveux
de plusieurs temps là que de la tôle
nous fait peur
[Musique]
pour ginette pigeons aux cheveux blonds
et courts
le postiche sera naturellement à cheveux
blancs et l'ensemble vous allez en juger
postiches et cheveux sourire et beaux
yeux et extrêmement séduisant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rue debelleyme le cours normales
d'enseignement ménager de paris a choisi
la puériculture comme thème de son
exposition 1957
voici les travaux de ces jeunes filles
futurs professeurs d'enseignement
ménager pendant deux ans elles ont réuni
et fort bien présentes et vous pouvez le
voir toute la documentation sur la
première enfance recherches minutieuses
variées elles les aideront à devenir de
bons professeurs de puériculture des
élèves des cours d'enseignement ménager
en voici elles sont soixante quinze
mille de 11 à 17 ans dans les écoles
communales à paris et dans la cei
[Musique]
la croissance l'alimentation l'hygiène
de bébé pour elles n'auront plus de
secrets et quand tu es jeunes filles
apprennent la puériculture les enfants
se portent mieux
la mortalité diminue chez les tout
petits
non
dans les cours d'enseignement ménager on
fait aussi la cuisine du repassage du
raccommodage de la couture et de
l'économie domestique bien sûr
[Musique]
le
puériculture et géographie au sénégal
bébé et beauté attaché à sa mère par une
bande de toiles caché par les chats
mademoiselle mathiot parce que plus
générale chez les indiens sioux le petit
nuage rouge est glissée dans un étui d'
un étui en pot
[Musique]
au pays des eskimos flocons de neige est
blotti dans le capuchon de l'anorak mais
la nuit il dort tout nu dans les bras de
sa mère le bébé de la belle hindoue a
pour tout costume une chaîne d'or autour
de la taille et du col autour des yeux
contre les microbes rétrospective ivème
siècle avant jésus-christ gracieux
évocation du bas relief de la prade
cette beauté grecs à deux jumeaux
emmailloté les mains le long du corps
[Musique]
elle a aussi une jeune nourrice
on
15e siècle aucassin est entouré de
bandelettes et catherine sa nourrice a
été choisie parce qu'elle a l'oeil clair
le visage agréable capote et crinoline
le second empire sied bien à la féminité
élégance aussi pour la robe de bébés
fine lingerie et dentelle
[Musique]
autre temps autre méthode
mais partout et toujours les mêmes
gestes tendres les petits gestes
protecteur de l'amour maternel
ainsi s'achève le magazine féminin
[Musique]